[voix OFF]
Est-il devenu invisible depuis le premier janvier ?
Oui un petit peu invisible, c'est vrai!
Mais là, j'suis là!
C'est pas une vraie vidéo comme d'habitude,
Je vais essayer d'être très concis.
Je me suis dis, on est quand même le 3 janvier,
il serait temps que je leur dise
ce que je compte faire cette année.
*bruit de stylo sur le bureau*
bah, je vais faire des vidéos...
Alors, si je vous disais tout ce que je vais faire
cette année c'est trop long,
donc on va faire court.
On va juste parler du mois de janvier.
Dans un premier je vais prendre
quelques jours de vacances,
mais vous allez avoir déjà une vidéo
ce vendredi matin!
Parce que, j'ai tourné une vidéo et je vois pas pourquoi je ne la sortirais pas.
Ensuite, c'est sûr pendant 15 jours il va y avoir moins, beaucoup moins de vidéos que d'habitude.
Puisque avant c'était une par jour.
Pour la simple et bonne raison que
je vais me reposer un peu.
En apparence...
Parce qu'en réalité, je commence ma tournée...
Par exemple, le 6 et le 7 janvier
je suis à Lille dans le 59
Le 11 et le 12 janvier
je suis à Saint Galmier dans le 42
Le 13 janvier à Villars dans le 42 aussi
Le 14 janvier Vienne dans le 38,
comme le 15 janvier
Le 20 et le 21 janvier dans le 83
à Brignoles
et du 25 au 29 janvier dans le 13
à Aix en Provence.
A chaque fois on se verra à la fin des spectacles,
je prends du temps avec vous!
Les dernières fois qu'on a fait ça en Suisse et à Paris,
on a passé plus de temps à se voir après,
que le spectacle en lui même.
Et c'est cool,
j'aime bien!
Bref, pour les dates du spectacle,
vous avez un lien dans la description.
Donc concernant les vidéos,
un petit peu de pause au départ et puis
après je vais reprendre
à deux, trois vidéos par semaine.
Ça dépendra des semaines,
dans un premier temps
il n'y a pas de jour spécifique de sortie.
Il n'y aura pas d'heure spécifique de sortie,
donc vraiment,
cliquez sur la petite cloche
pour être sûr d'être notifiés et de pas rater les vidéos.
Et il y aura une vidéo ou deux
un petit peu plus grosses et spéciales
dont une qui sortira qu'à la toute fin du mois,
le dernier jour de janvier.
Ce sera une grosse vidéo,
avec une grosse surprise dedans.
Et puis c'est tout!
Forcément comme j'ai eu un petit peu plus de temps,
je me suis pas mal éclaté
pour monter la vidéo de vendredi.
J'espère vraiment que ça vous plaira
et que vous serez au rendez-vous pour la voir.
Je ne serai pas tout seul, je serai dedans avec quelqu'un
et je vous donnerai un indice dans cette vidéo.
A vous de le trouver.
Une dernière chose,
j'ai bien lu tous vos commentaires
sur ce que vous aimeriez voir ou pas sur la chaine
et ça m'a beaucoup servi.
Donc merci beaucoup.
Et si !
Autre chose :
Je vais lancer des vidéos qui vont se faire avec vous,
des espèces d’expériences qu'on va faire ensemble.
Donc suivant les besoins,
à chaque fois, soit je ferais une vidéo
ça s'appellera  :
" Expérience.
Est-ce que vous voulez participer ? "
quelque chose comme ça.
Et tout sera expliqué dedans
et parfois, ça sera plus simple à faire,
et je mettrai directement un message
sur les réseaux sociaux,
vous avez aussi les liens dans la description.
Je crois que je n'ai rien oublié
si ce n'est que
de vous souhaiter une
très très très très bonne année 2017
Ça fait bizarre de ne plus avoir plein de commentaires
à lire tous les jours
et voilà, c'est un nouveau rythme qui s'installe.
A très bientôt,
à vendredi...
... matin !
OVER!!
[Musique Générique de fin]